[Applause]
this is very unusual in China
police truck among the targets the
frustration of the Fed Up spilling over
in this District of Guangzhou City
people are in a hard lockdown and enough
clearly felt like enough the constant
drive for zero covered straining
cases are mounting across this country
but over a thousand miles away there is
a hint of a shift in approach
this is Xi jaduin despite appearances
it's a place where cases are ticking up
but testing is winding down
here only the vulnerable now have to
show negative results to enter some
public places
a change you'd think would be welcomed
by young people like the Guan sisters
there is some relief but trepidation too
much
the changes mean fewer testing booths
here those that remain have very long
cues and very long weights years of
messaging that people should fear the
virus May well be hard to shake
are you worried I asked this man
I'm worried I'll infect others and then
affect me he says
but it feels hugely significant without
testing it's hard to see how zero covert
holds authorities here insist they're
not loosening covert restrictions
they're simply optimizing them that this
is just one of the first places in the
country to implement a new directive to
be more targeted with pandemic control
but either way it feels like something
of a test case for a country at a
pivotal Crossroads a big wave of
infections is almost certainly coming
how the government chooses to respond in
the coming weeks could well be
indicative
there is a nervousness about the Optics
here police interrupted our filming men
in plain clothes followed us all
afternoon
any move away from zero covert does come
with risk but this Flagship policy is
faltering and there's a sense the
authorities know it Helen Ann Smith Sky
News she judging Herbie province